[Music]
in countries all around the world the
coronavirus pandemic brought large parts
of the economy to a standstill many
companies only survived through
government aid and some didn't make it
at all
[Music]
like in taiwan where the tourism
industry is still struggling
[Music]
in other parts of the world like
zimbabwe the pandemic gave rise to whole
new services
but we start off in germany where nearly
all kovid 19 restrictions were lifted at
the start of april
it's a huge relief to many businesses
especially nightclubs and restaurants
[Music]
the masks and social distancing measures
are gone and revelers can once again
enjoy berlin nightlife with their old
freedoms
germany dropped most of its coronavirus
restrictions at the beginning of april
for partygoers it was a moment they'd
been waiting for for a long time and now
they're ready to celebrate
i just had coronas so i thought when if
not now
it still feels a bit different but it's
my first time back i think the sense of
ease will return when there are more
concerts again
the pandemic hit the club industry
harder than most shuttered for two years
only state aid prevented widespread
bankruptcies
but pamela showbiz of the berlin club
commission fears the difficult times are
not over yet
yes
now that this financial assistance is
coming to an end we'll see if nightclubs
will survive or not
for two years night clubs were able to
ratchet down from 100 to zero percent
they had no choice
but it's clear that from one day to the
next we can't suddenly go from zero to a
hundred percent
the hospitality industry is also reeling
due to the impact of the coronavirus and
covet restrictions revenue dropped about
40 percent over the past two years the
erdinger restaurant in the center of
berlin managed to survive but many
others were less fortunate state aid
couldn't compensate for the huge losses
they incurred
also
it led to massive restaurant closures
lots of restaurant owners had to close
because they weren't in as good a
location as us
or couldn't get into the to-go business
those two things actually helped us a
lot
but restauranteurs who didn't have these
things
who maybe had a nice restaurant but were
on a side street without much traffic
they just didn't stand a chance
there's also a shortage of hospitality
staff after many people left the
industry
the impact of the pandemic can be seen
everywhere germany's gdp has suffered
the economy grew last year but by 2.7
percent less than hoped
so should restrictions have been eased
sooner
you just have to look and you'll see how
many shops here are empty
talk to people who are on reduced
working hours or who work in department
stores my opinion it's time enough
already
what does safe means
we're moving into an endemic situation
we'll have to live with
just like the flu and other illnesses
i think it's good to get back to more
freedoms
but just dropping mask requirements in
so many places and people coming
together in big crowds again
it's a bit strange and it will take some
getting used to
germany's government decided that
sectors that were hard hit by the crisis
need a bit more freedom again also with
the argument that infections with the
omicron variant have been comparatively
mild
none of us trust this law
we all think it will hit again next fall
we're worried that the authorities don't
realize that
that somehow we'll get through this
summer and then be surprised in the fall
when things get worse and we have to
shut again
that's a big worry for all club
operators
we've only just reopened and already
thinking about what would happen if we
need to close again
it would really be a catastrophe
more freedom and reviving sectors hard
hit by crisis are appealing prospects
but the end of the restrictions bring
new coronavirus waves where the
long-term damage could be even greater
the pandemic has also been devastating
to taiwan's tourism industry
the island's government imposed strict
entry rules for travelers which kept
infection rates low
but it also denied many businesses their
customer base
more than a hundred hotels have been
forced to close since the start of the
pandemic due to the lack of visitors
[Music]
jenny khan is on her way to workplace a
hotel working the same routes she's
taken for the past 20 years by this time
she is going there to take one last look
taipei's imperial hotel is set to
demolished
it has two clothes last october because
business was down due to kobe 19.
the imperial hotel opened in 1967 and i
was born that same year
we're the same age
seeing the hotel in boone times and now
seeing it close makes me sad
ninety percent of the hotel's business
come from foreign guests but taiwan's
strict border controls put paid to that
management decided to lay off staff
there were 48 people in room service
but after the pandemic started our guest
numbers dropped
so we didn't need so many staff anymore
before the hotel closed we were down to
17.
the hotel was at least able to retain
its chinese restaurants and reopen it in
a different location
jenny khan was able to keep her job with
her colleagues she now sells food online
now the owner wants to open a new hotel
in a suburb in 2024 with a focus on
different types of guests
during the pandemic many people had
online meetings and worked from home
we expect a further decrease in business
travel so we want to concentrate on
tourists too
the imperial is not the only hotel in
taiwan that has had too close due to the
pandemic
more than 100 have shut down in past two
years
the sherwood is the latest
located in taipei city it has hosted
many political leaders for more than
three decades
but closed its door in february tourism
express fear that the continuing ban on
foreign visitors will hit the industry
hard
taken because they see that things are
not going well in tourism young people
don't want to enter the industry
then when we open the borders again only
older people will work in it
that was
not only hotels but also restaurants and
stores in tourist area are struggling
john worked for years in clothing store
and witnessed it go downhill
before the pandemic we almost had no
time for lunch or dinner
but now
says many restaurants they used to have
a long line now do not even require
reservations
that smoothie house used to be very
crowded before the pandemic
we had to wait in line for a long time
because it's very famous
but not anymore
taiwan may still have some of the lowest
kobe 19 infection rates in the world but
its strict entry rules have hit the
tourism industry hard as for jenny khan
although she enjoys learning new skills
in e-commerce she hopes to return to
room service in a hotel as soon as
possible
many companies around the world are
short staffed right now because their
workers have coven 19 and are isolating
at home
our science reporter derek williams has
spent the past two years following the
pandemic and as always he's here to
answer your questions
this time jimmy j wants to know
how long do covet 19 patients remain
infectious
this is of course not a hard and fast
number um because everyone has
unique immune responses to pathogens
the length of an infection after
contracting covet 19
varies from person to person and it also
depends on which variant that person
comes down with
that said
based on averages health care
authorities have set up guidelines for
isolation
it's important to know that what's
called
the incubation period for the disease so
how long it takes you to start showing
symptoms after being exposed
that that's pegged at between 2 and 14
days with more recent variants
incubation also tends to happen faster
after being infected with the omicron
variant for instance
most people will start to show symptoms
within about
three days and the general consensus
is that infected people who develop
symptoms
are most likely to infect others
in the day or two before they start to
show those symptoms themselves as well
as in the two or three days afterwards
so how long should you remain in
isolation to be at least relatively sure
that you won't
infect anyone else
their healthcare authorities like the
u.s centers for disease control draw
some distinctions based on how severe
your case of covet covid19 was
on its spectrum
people who had moderate to severe
illness
should isolate for a minimum of 10 days
with that period being extended
to 20 or even more days for people who
are immunocompromised because
in some cases they can shed live virus
for longer
but the cdc and other health authorities
now also generally assume
that otherwise healthy people who had
only mild cases
or were asymptomatic are probably only
contagious for a maximum of 10 days
after the first symptoms appear and
possibly shorter
so that's why under newer guidelines if
a patient is recovering and has
no more traces of fever
they can end isolation after only five
days but they should wear a mask around
others for five more days after that
because they might still be infectious
other countries have slightly different
rules here in germany for example you
can end isolation after seven days with
a negative antigen or pcr test
without one you have to isolate for 10
days but the underlying logic
is similar it's that to be on the safe
side
you should assume that even if you had a
mild case of covet 19 or had no symptoms
at all
you might be infectious for up to 10
days after you had your first symptoms
or had a positive test result
for the first time
[Music]
while some industries have been hit hard
by the pandemic others have flourished
delivery services have seen huge demand
thanks to lockdown and quarantine rules
in zimbabwe one startup not only created
lots of jobs
the company also became a lifeline for
people stuck at home with no other way
of buying food
[Music]
yay thank you so much receiving food
orders right at the doorstep has become
a convenient and safe option for some
residents in zimbabwe's capital harare
for current young
online shopping innovations helped her
reduce the risk of infection during the
peak of the pandemic
she regularly orders a fresh produce and
food from the online startup afresh in a
box
it's been a life saver i'm a single mum
so as you can see i have a small
child so for me going to the supermarket
along with the worry of infection
has also been the time factor so even
now that things are a little bit less in
from a covered perspective i still find
the deliveries invaluable just to saving
me time
online shopping is steadily growing in
zimbabwe and it has brought many
services closer to citizens in the
comfort of their homes
kodamo sasiwa
founded the family run startup afresh in
a boxer
customers can order fresh vegetables
fruits and some additional food items
online
our innovation has made
shopping for for the everyday individual
very very easy they go on their phones
they order from us and then we deliver
to their homes obviously with covet 19
making this the new normal um during the
big panics and the big
lockdowns we became ubiquitous and
became you know absolutely necessary for
those homes the coronavirus pandemic has
been a real boost to the online startup
company
after it was founded in 2018
it only saved an average of 120
customers a day until covered lockdowns
started
now that has showed up to more than a
thousand
for fresh in a boxer
adapting to a fast changing environment
has not always been easy
and the pandemic has brought many
challenges
the unpredictability of policies has
also been quite crazy so sometimes
you're locked down sometimes you're not
locked down uh you know a vaccination is
going in are you allowed to do this
without so there's been a lot of rules
that we've had to learn to change and
drop and change and try and remain
compliant
at fresh farm
fresh in a box major source of
vegetables
being able to sell online helped save
farm produce that would have otherwise
gone to waste because of covered
lockdowns what i've learned from the
pandemic is that you know
humanity needs to find ways of being
more sustainable in the way that it
eats in the way that it grows
in the way that it survives
we are going to have to find ways of
socializing which that is not direct
contact we're going to have to find ways
of survival in a space where we're not
as closely knit as we used to be
the coronavirus pandemic may have
brought many challenges for farmers and
social innovators
but it has brought many good lessons to
consider for the future
[Music]
for those who don't get their food
delivered and aren't keen on going to
the supermarket other ways of procuring
food have emerged during the pandemic
the colombian capital bogota now has
over 4 000 urban gardens that are
keeping entire family supplied with
homegrown fruit and vegetables
and aside from providing food many find
the gardening itself quite therapeutic
[Music]
working in the garden is the perfect
start to the day for diego gutierrez
he farms a small green strip in front of
his house it was the first city garden
of its kind to be officially approved in
bogota
the idea of creating a garden started
during the pandemic when we were all
cooped up inside
being confined like that felt awful
so the residents got together and worked
out how we could stop ourselves from
going stir crazy and decided to start a
garden
it also made sense because certain food
items were hard to come by
the public space in front of our house
seemed like a good place it was in poor
condition and homeless people often left
their garbage on it so the first thing
we had to do was clean it up
then we could start learning how to be
gardeners
there were a few things diego gutierrez
first needed to learn
but now his harvests are pretty good
tomatoes onions coffee plants lettuce
and cabbage all thrive on what used to
be a neglected strip of land
the urban gardens also offer a second
chance to farmers who fled to the city
to escape the violence in other parts of
colombia
the city authorities assigned mariela
pardo a plot of land and she's been
farming it ever since
i'm used to working in the field so i
was happy when they gave us this little
piece of land
because then at least we had something
to do
it keeps me fit
i turned 66 in february so that's
important
working in the field is good for my
health and clears my mind
[Music]
mariela pardo once learned how to farm
from her father
now she's passing on that knowledge to
her grandson luis
[Music]
the initiative is supported by the
city's botanic gardens
they organize special days where people
can plant things under supervision
they also provide classes
the larger goal is to promote local
agriculture
our goal is to provide more than forty
thousand people with technical
assistance and training to more than
twenty thousand people
and we want to supply basic tools to
more than twenty thousand community
gardens
the harvest from the gardens helps to
feed each family relieving the pressure
on household budgets
whenever she harvests something mariela
pardo always thinks about the farm she
lost
do this as long as god gives me the
strength
i'm so thankful for my garden
perhaps one day he'll help me to harvest
a little more
diego gutierrez believes the gardens
will help pave the way to a better
future a more sustainable vision of
progress in urban areas
making the city look pretty has always
meant concrete stone and nice pavement
but the gardens are far prettier and
more productive too
the pandemic has brought change to
bogota the new urban gardens have made
the city more green and are helping to
build strong communities
[Music]
many sectors were forced to adapt and
find ways to survive during the pandemic
for the performing arts it was
especially tough
in britain many theaters had to close
and so they sought alternative ways to
perform for the public
for actors directors and everyone
involved in theater it was often the
only way of safeguarding their
livelihood
[Music]
here in the heart of london's famous
theater district the days of covert
lockdowns almost seem like their own
work of fiction
in which a crowded auditorium was the
stuff of nightmares
but these theater enthusiasts are now
itching to get back to their seats
oh i think it's brilliant i think it's
exactly what we need oh it's absolutely
wonderful we've come all the way from
wales to see this hopefully everyone
inside will be wearing air master will
be fine i think i caught covered the
last time i went to the theater so okay
no not at all really looking forward to
it very excited
there's no fear anymore we're just sort
of back to normal to be honest
[Music]
after three lockdowns and months of
restrictions the west end slowly
bouncing back but for many smaller
independent theaters the legacy of
covert lingers
it's the worst thing you have to do if
you're a theater manager is close your
theater it just sort of was a
punch in the gut really
lockdowns saw the team at london's
orange tree theatre lose their
livelihoods overnight
asking people to come to
an intimate theater and we
prided ourselves and traded on being an
intimate theater all of our lives work
was now come to a point where what we
were dedicated to doing was both illegal
and toxic
since then at times it wasn't clear
whether the theater would ever reopen
two things
seemed very stark one was that
we were going to run out of money that
we would be bankrupt and
my experience of the british theatre is
that when theaters close
it's very difficult for them to reopen
so it was
fingertip staff really
you know it was an existential threat
issues
fast forward to today and restrictions
are lifted and the theater's back in
action rehearsing german drama tom foole
still she's german
oh german girls eh even the king of
sweden's hooked
she's got him in her grip
well like many theaters they survived
with the help of government support but
covert cases are soaring once again in
the uk and car's sickness is still
shutting down performances
audience sizes are also down
significantly on pre-pandemic levels
for some that's due to covert concerns
others are simply out of the habit
paul fears this could have a lasting
impact on smaller independent
theaters the great big blockbuster
theater experiences like andrew lloyd
webber's cinderella
is still very popular they'll spend a
lot of money on a big night out
but they won't go back to ending their
regular sums of money coming to see
a couple of plays a week if they're not
absolutely sure they're going to have a
good time but the show must go on and if
coverts taught them anything it's how to
adapt
restrictions accelerated their move
online they started streaming
performances to help stay afloat
their digital content is now not only
reaching new audiences it's an important
financial lifeline people that either
can't come in the first place because of
the pandemic
or find coming coming physically to the
theater anyway very difficult now have
access to our work in a way that they
didn't before it's been a process born
out of necessity but it's fulfilled a
long-term dream
and with that the stage is set for a new
post-covered future
where once the move online may have felt
a challenge too far
now it's a ray of hope and a sign that
theater in whatever form will always
find a way to endure bring me the other
one
[Music]
the pandemic wreaked havoc in many
industries while for others it opened up
new opportunities
it also highlighted how globally
interconnected we are just think of all
the interruptions to supply chains for
example
we'll return to that thought in our next
show exploring the concept of one health
we'll see how the health of humans
animals and our environment are all
linked together
until then
take care
[Music]
you